هذه يعني التصريحات التي تاتي من المتحدث
باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي عن استمرار
المواجهات الشرسه بعد كل هذه الفتره من
بدء العمليه البريه وبعد كل هذا القصف
الذي اوقع
دمارا اشارت واشنطن بوست الى جانب منه وفي
المقابل الفيديوهات والصور التي تبثها
سرايا القدس والقسام للمواجهات بين
الجانبين والدفعات الصاروخيه الكبيره التي
تنطلق من من قطاع غزه حتى
باتجاه المدن الاسرائيليه الرئيسيه الى اي
مدى يكون ذلك فكره واضحه عن سير العمليات
في القطاع حتى
[موسيقى]
الان محمود دعنا نضع ما تفضلت فيه في هذا
السؤال بمنظار مفهومي او كونسبت كما يقال
يعني هناك اربعه او
خمسه مدى او ابعاد تخاط فيها الحرب هناك
البر البحر الجو الفضاء ومن ثم البعد
السيبراني ويضاف حاليا في هذه الحرب البعد
الاعلامي يعني المقاومه تقارع اسرائيل في
مجالين فقط اليوم في البر تحت الارض وفي
الاعلام يعني اليوم ابو عبيده عندما يقول
ويؤكد بفيديوهات معينه انما لمزيد من
المصداقيه ولكن البر هو الجزء الاساسي
لانه اسرائيل لا يمكن لها ان تجلب كل
الابعاد الباقيه البر والجو والبحر
والفضاء للقتال في غزه البر هو البعد
الاساسي وقوه المقاومه فوق الارض وتحت
الارض يعني عندما انت
تعقد امكانيه العدو ان يحقق اهدافه بسرعه
يعني على سبيل المثال بن جورين يقول باحدى
مفاهيم الاستراتيجيه الكبرى الاسرائيليه
حسم الحرب بسرعه عدم الذهاب الى حرب ايه
استنزاف لانه الجيش الاسرائيلي هو جيش
احتياط يقوم الاقتصاد عليه هنا عندما اطلت
الحرب وانزلت الكثير من الخسائر انما اخذت
هذا الجيش الى حرب لم يعتد عليها وهو
يقاتل بعكس العقيده العسكريه التي تدرب
عليها الى اي مدن يستطيع نتنياهو مواصله
هذه الحرب بالوتير القائمه او الراهنه
حاليا ا وهو هو يؤكد طول الوقت انه يعني
من يعتقد ان هذه الحرب ستتوقف قبل تحقيق
الاهداف الثلاثه الكبرى التي اعلن عنها
فهو واهم او منفصل عن
الواقع هناك امران يمنعان من تحقيق
الاهداف اولا هذه الحرب في هذه الحده الان
تنسي وصلت الى ما يسمى كما يقول كاربون
كلاوزفيتز الى نقطه الزروه او الكشن يعني
يعني هي في هذه المرحله هذا الصعود تصل
الى مرحله مرحله الذروه بعدها يبدا
المردود يكون اقل بكثير من الاستثمار هنا
اذا اذا استمرت هذه الحرب على الوتيره
يبدا الخساره الكبيره للجيش الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي لنتنياهو هذا الامر فاذا من هنا
تغيير او اعاده الانتشار والحديث دائما عن
المنطقه العازله هذا اول امر مهم من هنا
التغيير وصحب القوات واعاده انتشار الامر
الثاني هو الضغط الامريكي واعطاء نتنياهو
والجيش الاسرائيلي فتره الى نصف يناير
2024 لاعاده ترتيب الوضع وبالتالي التعامل
مع حاله جديده والا سيكون هناك خسائر
مستمره ان كان في العتاد او في العديد او
حتى في معنويات الجيش اليوم عندما نتحدث
عن الاعلام محمود يمنع الصحافه
الاسرائيليه من تغطيه سياده العميد هناك
خبر عاجل عذرا على المقاطعه عذرا على
المقاطعه هناك خبر عاجل يفيد في هذا
التحليل اذ يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي ان احد
جنوده اصيب بصاروخ مضاد للدروع اطلقه حزب
الله باتجاه بلده المناره يعني
مساله تسخين الجبهه الشماليه بالنسبه
لاسرائيل على هذا النحو في خضم المعارك
التي تخوضها بشراسه او تواجهها في قطاع
غزه بهذه الصوره هل يضيف ذلك الى الطين
بلا ايه هو اشغال اسرائيل على عده جبهات
على الجبهه ال الجبهه الجنوبيه في غزه
جبهه جنوب لبنان ولكن دمن قواعد اجتباك
معينه هي بدات بالتصعيد الى درجه يمنع
الجيش الاسرائيلي من خوط حرب لانه ليس
قادرا بالحد الادنى الوسائل ليست متوفره
وبالاضافه الى الضغط الامريكي لعدم توسيع
هذا الامر بالاضافه الى ما جرى من العراق
والمسيرات باتجاه كريش وباتجاه ايلاك وما
يجري في اليمن يعني اليوم انت اكثرت
واغرقت اسرائيل بالكثير من المشاكل
الامنيه وبالكثير من المشاكل الامنيه التي
تغرق عمل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
الخليج فاذا انت امام عده جبهات لا يمكن
التنفيذ عليها كلها يجب وضع الاولويات في
المقابل في تقديرك يعني الى اي مدى يمكن
للمقاومه ان تستمر في هذه الوتيره من
العمليات القتاليه القويه وهذه الوتيره من
اطلاق الصواريخ بهذه الكثافه على باتجاه
البلدات
الاسرائيليه
ا محمود البارحه تحدثنا انا وانت في نفس
الموضوع واليوم تبين انه هناك قذيفتان او
قنبلتان كبيرتان ب 2000 باوند كل واحد
واحده ما يقدر ب 2000 طن اعيد
استعمالها لتفجير خمسه دبابات ميركافا
وهذا امر مهم جدا لكن الجديد في الامر هو
جديد قديم لانه لدى حماس مشروع ما يسمى
بقصد السبيل وسوف اقرا اسم المهندس الشهيد
ابراهيم ابو النجا الذي هو ابتكر هذا
الامر يقوم على جمع القذائف غير المنفجره
من البر والبحر بعده انواع خاصه 155 اولا
تصنيفها لحمايه المدنيين افراغها اي بعدها
اعداد القذيفه صبها واستعمالها وبالتالي
خلقت اعاده التدوير ما يسمى باعاده
التدوير انا اعتقد اليوم ان بما انها لا
تزال تطلق هذه الصواريخ ولكن ب ب ب بعدد
اقل هذا امر مهم يعني هي اما تدرس المعركه
طويله واما هي تقتصد بما يسمى بالمخزون
الصاروخي لحركه حماس او المقاومه ككل شكرا
جزيلا لك سياده العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي كان معنا من بيروت